[Music]
all right guys
don't look recently
the gap clothing store i love the store
it's my favorite store ever of all time
don't lie they posted a very
controversial
hoodie that they had to apologize for
and they replaced the p
with another letter no you know i never
bought gap because people were like
that's gay and proud oh that's funny
when you know when you're in like
elementary school you're like you got
gab well you're gay and proud huh
and i was like is that what it stands
for and they're like yeah and i'm like
oh i didn't know it was a gay store
there is no greater company
and i will say this on the record
there's no greater company than the gap
thank you oh yeah okay cool
so they are in a very big controversy on
twitter
what have i done we're releasing a
sweatshirt hoodie
and it looks like this
is it a is it a blood in a [ __ ] no oh
that's right and left
what's wrong with that one wait what is
that well what's wrong bart is it says
the one thing we know
is that together we can move forward
is that backstage no there's no
libertarians oh this is police yeah
it's just republicans democrats oh it's
a political sweater two-party system
we need green that's not why they were
in trouble that's not why are they in
trouble
inciting gang well so i'll let me read
some of the tweets
i don't know what's happening um so
that people did not like it because
i just thought it was a cool color
combination but i guess it's pretty i
don't like it because the sweater looks
ugly
i can't see that far okay so like
because it's like a split journal
this is from one twitter users that says
thanks gap i'm gonna wear this on the
battlefield in the civil war to
symbolize how we should just be getting
along better
so is this like the coca-cola thing oh
god it's like the pepsi thing and the
stopping
the the kendall jenner one was that cold
no those pepsi pepsi pepsi wait what is
that guy referring to
that sounds crazy it's it's it's it's
pretty much being tone deaf to what's
going on
it's like oh here's here's the solution
our merchandise is that what it's like
is this like when peyton manning left
the cult and he became a bronco and then
they did the split jersey
no oh no it's not like that so these in
in this instance you know
we're in a the heat of the election
right now and we still don't have
results
true like a lot of people have a lot of
anxiety about
the results of the election and it can
very much feel like
everyone's on opposite sides you know
and so anything that
says like hey we could come together is
basically saying it's basically like
belittling the problems that are at
stake damn for reals
that's crazy because all the laws
everything is bipartisan everything
you know yeah but right now but i think
capitalizing
to make a profit off of it is the issue
that's another thing
i mean that's so to me that's like
that's that's their business whatever
right but
to me it feels crazy because it's
imagine you have two homies that are
about to throw down right they're gonna
fight
and then you have the one homie coming
in hey man let's not fight right now and
that's the guy that's getting pummeled
the guy
that's saying hey let's not fight is
selling shirts to the fight yeah
and then coming in and saying that's
what it is hey don't
fight let's unite but buy them you know
for sure if that says it's 45 by the way
right
it's one of those things i i get where
it is it's like profiting off uh a tense
time
yes i think that's where it's like yeah
that's that's part of it totally tone
deaf
i get it it definitely feels like the
pepsi ad but like not as bad it's like
one step lower
wait remind me the pepsi and the pepsi
ad was like here's all this protest
because it was around the
end times and it was like protest
protest protest it's police
so then she comes out out of the protest
miley no
kendall kendall kendall it was in
reference he was a pepsi to the police
and then they opened it and everybody
was like yeah
problem solved it was in reference to
you know back
the the flower in the gun it was a it
was it was a nod to that thinking that
they were doing something symbolic of
a piece and it
instead and so that's what's going on
it's a cell pattern the sad part is
trump and biden are probably texting
each other [ __ ] around still while
like the whole nation is like going i
know right
so i have friends of friends that work
deep in the white house and
what goes on behind curtains it's not
we don't know but a lot of them they
communicate they're just
buds they play this political theater so
they could be like oh would you eat for
breakfast yesterday oh i had [ __ ]
pancakes
somebody on the inside probably works at
gap or somebody told someone at gab like
you know what
this is going to make some money right
now i mean it's just tone deaf they
they just wanted to profit off of the
situation i think it looks ugly too i
wish the leaders exposed
some of it so we're not so much conflict
it's not an original concept
let's just be a thousand percent red and
blue zip up hoodie they just try to
capitalize on this
i went to a broncos game when the colts
were playing them and then
people had the split jersey it looks so
bad in person i told people
they're like he's a bronco and a cult
and i'm like you look like an
idiot dude if that was a dope design
though i think it would bring america
together
it could like it only takes a dope
hoodie
to bring to solve the whole world's
problems good campaign it wasn't a dope
enough hoodie
no it's ugly that's the problem i don't
know it looks like a clown's
shirt you're right so if we've replaced
the pepsi ad with a coke i think we
could have
oh hell yeah dude would have been much
better like who solves [ __ ] with pepsi
like coke yeah [ __ ] yeah i could see
that what other tweets were there
some people were comparing it to the
cake to siding with the kkk
oh [ __ ] wait why wow wait where did they
get that from
people i wish they had trump from home
alone too
telling kevin hey it's down the hall to
the left and then they had biden
they'd like superimpose them in the
hallway he's like come on man
i think that would be great yeah that's
all you need to do wait then add that
that's my ad yeah when does the sweater
come into play
so they're both wearing it they're both
wearing it
i thought i was clear about that no you
weren't you didn't say my bad man
well you know i i had to imagine the
millions and
millions and millions so and then some
people came out in support of the brand
they were like you monsters made gap
delete a tweet that encouraged people to
move forward together
no matter who wins this insanity isn't
going anywhere if they
posted it without the intent of making a
profit off of it
then that would you think that if they
made it a giveaway i wouldn't even say
there needs to be merchandise gap
just like a tweet by itself i feel like
i'll save some [ __ ] just something
if you actually are being genuine you're
not gonna profit off of it but if you
are a corporation and you want to make
money
tapatio can bring us all together and we
can find something that is related but
don't they gotta do something in this
in the name of their brand but you don't
have to sell it even tapatio is a
corporation
the director of specialty brands and
communications for gap said from the
start we've been a brand that bridges
the gap between individuals cultures and
generations
the intention of our social media post
that featured a red and blue hoodie was
to show the power of unity it was just
too soon for this message
we remain optimistic that our country
will come together to drive positive
change for all
welcome to the time where damned if you
do damned if you don't on
certain situations because just
depending on who is watching your brand
but again if you read the room
read the room sometimes it's better to
not say anything and sometimes it's
better to be
really strategic with your message
it's tough there's no there's i really
missed the days that we had sarah palin
porn
and i think all americans would accept
is that we need to have presidential
porn
right and then we need to come together
yeah i do well not
just for unity yeah i don't know if
anyone wants to see it
no i mean like it doesn't have to be
them but like it's just kind of like
they're in an orgy together and you see
a collaboration
of the senate dangling and it feels a
little bit more lighthearted than it
does now
yeah yeah because right now it feels a
lot like there's a lot of tension in the
air
i missed celebrity death match oh i love
that that would have been
i miss celebrities is that the
claymation yeah and tv man
that is when you can throw people in and
be
unapologetic they could twist people's
heads off yeah
like a lot of people are characters it's
just like hyped up and then you throw
them in the ring and then everybody's
understanding what they're talking about
and they just i feel like our
presidential candidates are
characters of course match would be
dope between the two of them and you'd
probably get actually more facts out of
it
i think they would put all of all of
what's going on on both sides and then
they just
can we just have like an all-american
eating contest and see who will win
frank's hockey we'll have different
kinds of like you know like some
you know july barbecue challenges like
tug of war
like whatever and whoever wins the most
things summer camp that becomes the pres
yeah they because they feel like who
could eat more
hot dogs trump i feel like who could eat
who could maybe move more
by den biden will probably win the sack
race and
the wheelbarrow race the wheelbarrow
yeah who wins the dance battle
probably trump have you seen his [ __ ]
hand moves the american people lose
he found a loophole in dancing he's like
you don't even have to move your body
just move your hands that's
smart it's like the shoulder move very
smart by the way smart
yeah i just read one of the sidebar
headlines and it says michigan attorney
general asks residents to stop telling
staff to shove sharpies up their butts
what yeah we live in a great time
we live in a great time this is a just
for another storm the sharpies
wow we're talking about just wanting
presidents to like we just want a
wheelbarrow race
potato sack maybe a bar but this is
reality like you
your guys's thing is less crazy than
what's actually
the headline put a sharpie up your butt
i just want sandlot in 2020. i just want
like a good old american baseball game
and having a crush on somebody at the
pool and fireworks
that'll be that'll be nice i want to go
back to that yeah
i don't even like apple pie that much
but i want something i just watched
and i was like this is our world
documentary
it's a duck it's yeah it's predicting
the future that was from like 15 years
ago
no that's gonna be nice
i can't wait i can't wait you know it's
gonna be a great world
i purposely don't watch black mirror
because of all this stuff
yeah dude it's too real now black mirror
is terrifying
why do you gotta make it so scary though
it's really scary because it's like
where technology can go what do you guys
think the worst is gonna happen
what do you mean like like like you know
how everyone's talking about civil yeah
like a lot of people talk about civil
war like
that's what well biden isn't our abe
lincoln so i don't know if anyone will
really fight for him
nah i think i don't think people are
fighting nobody's fighting for either of
them so that well
that's the whole thing right is that
everyone feels like i didn't get to vote
for who i wanted
i think that's what people will be
pissed off or is it going to be a
leaderless civil war where people are
just fighting within each city
i mean no i think there's definitely
people die hard fans yeah i mean that's
why there are people with like
big giant flags it's not like oh yeah
i'll settle for trump it's like
[ __ ] oh wait
i can't wait for harris yeah even
charlemagne was saying that
basically he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
uh biden he just wants
harris so at the end of the day
drink your water get a lot of sleep did
you hear that you hear her hydra
you hear your water get a lot of sleep
exercise
download the calm app eat healthy eat
healthy
don't drink too many steves because uh
you won't be able to drive home
i drink a lot of steve's i bet you do
drink a lot of
steve what is a steve help the people
what's a joke
some red bull some vodka and a good
amount of ice
i made that for my dude he's enjoying it
and i hope that you enjoy
steve too tonight and god bless
[Music]
[Music]
you